on va passer aux trophées de la dance de
l'année la dance de l'année et oui cette
catégorie dance de l'année on va voir
qui est nommé c'est parti pour le
trophée de la meilleure danse
hague à tobrouk
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
maxime gainey
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
isabelle morini bosc
[Musique]
ouais ouais
[Applaudissements]
alerte
du lot les palettes restreignent
gilles verdez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on vous avez une souris dans le site et
non jamin castaldi
voilà
ouais
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jan adam cole haan est tombé à ces
nouveautés du tout agathe à gaja volet
sexy agathe sa volkswagen avoue jean-luc
benjamin sexy pour moi à l'inventer un
truc à l'inventer une danse mine de rien
c'est vrai est là elle a son style est
la grande gagnante c'est bien sûr c'est
agathe et le gagnant un gâteau proulx
[Applaudissements]